[Music]
about two months after we got engaged my
parents told me they were taking back
the blessing and rattled off an
extensive list of red flags that they
saw in my fiance and our relationship
they didn't really like his career
choice he's a magician and a juggler but
he works in
ministries what is going on this is John
with the Dr John balone
show show about your mental health your
emotional
health your husband your wife whoever
you're dating whatever is going on in
your world your kids I'm here to walk
alongside you Show's made up of real
people going through real challenging
moments and quite honestly all of us
it's a it's a there just a like a dark
cloud hanging over all of us right now
as we record this and um lots of
ugliness out in the world and um so if
nothing else my hope with this show is
just modeling what it looks like to sit
down and say I hear you um pull up a
seat and let's figure out what we can do
next because I know this I know running
away from problems does not help I know
yelling at each other doesn't help and I
know
um a bunch of pseudo so-called experts
just launching Instagram posts at each
other doesn't help either what we have
to do is sit with real people and say I
hear you or can I ask this question or
hey man what do you think about this cuz
what we're doing is not working
so thank you so much for joining us if
you're ready to live some sort of
different life don't forget to pick up
building a non-exist life my new book it
is out number one bestseller Wall Street
Journal um I'm really proud of this one
and go pick it up and uh and don't
forget the questions for humans will
save your holidays go to John dooney.com
all right let's roll out to Georgia and
talk to the great and wonderful Matt
what's up Matt hey John Dr John how are
you I'm partying man what about you I'm
living the dream I
guess man I I I want to wake up from my
dream sometimes what's up yeah yeah yeah
exactly so um the question I have is the
current situation between my wife and I
um isn't great um I'm actually about to
move out into an apartment okay um what
what happened so to give you some
backstory I went through a period of
time where I drank too much on the
weekends basically Friday night Saturday
Sunday um what's a period of time I
would say probably a year and a half two
years just kind of out of the
blue um I would say it ramped up after
I've got two daughters five and three
and I would say it ramped up after my
second daughter was born okay
cool um so it was something my wife had
confronted me about um more than one
occa on more than one occasion and it
came to a head on Memorial day um my
oldest daughter the 5-year-old came out
on the deck where I was to ask me a
question and actually ended up falling
through a weak part in the railing about
12 feet and landed on concrete below
that fell you fell or she fell she fell
my daughter fell okay so um rushed to
the emergency room um they did X-rays
and all that found a small fracture in
her jaw a few days later we took her
with specialist he said it was the best
case scenario she'd be good to go in
like three weeks to a month no surgeries
needed just don't let her eat hard candy
basically and stuff yeah um man I'm so
sry after that I appreciate it man it
was rough and um after that my wife had
told me she's like listen I don't know
if I'm going to be able to bounce back
from this um what what did you have to
do with what
happened well I would say her falling
could have happened with any body being
out there um the problem was is that
with my drinking too much I was letting
things go around the house becoming
disconnected with my wife and my kids um
and even my job during the week when I
didn't drink was starting to suffer some
so um I put the blame on myself as far
as not fixing the railing um putting on
the back
burner um but something else hold on
something else happened that that was a
final straw for your wife you not paying
attention out there were you goofing off
no I was but I I had had two beers at
that point and before we took my
daughter to the emergency room I told my
wife I had not had any and of course all
she's got to do is look in the trash can
and see two beer
cans and um that was what triggered her
um her reaction more so than anything
else and um can I be honest with hold on
hold on can I be honest with you man
something's not adding up to me yes sir
if if if you and I are going to talk
you're gonna have to be 100% open well
no and like I said I I just wasn't
honest with her about when and how much
I was drinking yeah but two beers is not
hey we're done well I think it was more
the fact that I lied to her and told her
I hadn't been drinking than the amount
that I had been
drinking um and the the fact that it
happened on more than one
occasion that you'd had two
beers no no no I mean normally I would
drink more than that but I'm saying at
the point when this happened it wasn't
that I had been drinking necessarily it
was I lied about the fact that I had
been
drinking
okay I'm struggling with it but go ahead
continue so she said I can't come back
from this she said that at that time so
um I put forth a good bit of effort I
completely stopped
drinking um really worked on being
emotionally there for my kids kids and
my wife and not just physically there
started exercising again losing some
weight all the all the you know good
things that come along with Lifestyle
Changes um went on a family vacation had
a really good time skip ahead to Labor
Day
um I was kind of having an off weekend
we went out on a date Saturday I wasn't
really communicating with her um I was
supposed to get the girls ready for
church on Sunday I didn't have them
ready when it was time to leave I could
tell something was off with my wife
um that night she actually told me that
she was kind of trying to make herself
fall back in love with me but it hadn't
happened um she just couldn't let go of
the things that had
happened and at that point she said she
thought it' be best if I found an
apartment so so be super clear with me
man your daughter had an accident that
you had two two beers by any stretch of
the imagination you weren't close to
intoxicated right she fell out and got
hurt yes from that moment your wife said
I don't think we're going to be able to
come back from this now you didn't tell
your wife the truth about two beers what
were you doing those other times you
were drunk because
you here here's the deal you're you're
speaking very evasively and you're
speaking very distant from you know I
would I had a beer and then like you
know like maybe I wasn't your wife is
preferring to a single mom with two kids
than be with you well the problem was is
that say for example we get the kids
ready for bed put them in their bath get
them ready for bed and everything I had
already been drinking so she felt like
it wasn't safe to have the kids around
me and I didn't do anything violent I
wasn't abusive I didn't black out or
pass out or anything I just basically
drank more than I should
have
so you didn't hit anybody you didn't
cheat on your wife you didn't swear at
anybody
no your wife just said I'm
out well things got better for a while
until like I said the Labor Day weekend
which is when she made that decision
about I think it'd be better if you got
an apartment and what was her reasoning
behind that because she in the P she
didn't trust me anymore um she didn't
feel secure with me um she wasn't in
love with me
anymore
um and to be honest two weeks after that
when I had an apartment and I was
getting ready to move out we listened to
a snippet from one of your shows that
was kind of in the same vein is what I'm
going through right now and after we
listened to it she said I don't want you
to move out but if you want this to work
I need these things to
happen and basically it was me being
more involved in the finances me
continuing to um improve my relationship
with her and the
girls um but unfortunately after a
couple more weeks things hadn't really
gotten any better and the decision was
made again for me to just find an
apartment and that's where we're at
right now okay have yall G to get sit
down with a
professional yes we're going to couples
counseling and I'm also going
individually have youall already started
that or you're going to go we already
started the couples last week was my
first week that I met with my therapist
okay and is
anything coming up in coup's counseling
that is is an aha moment for the both of
you no um I mean she said some things
that were kind of an aha to me but
nothing that myself or the therapist is
saying have really triggered anything
for
her she says that nothing's changed as
far as her feelings and she basically
said there's nothing I can do which of
course there are things I could do to
make the situation
worse but as far as helping her get past
what she's holding on to there's nothing
I can
do
so there's a missing piece here um and
I've just had this conversation too too
often one of two things is true either
your wife has been looking for an exit
strategy for a season
now and or slowly got so far away from
you that she feels that she can't come
back that's number one or number two you
are using language and anybody who's
hung out with people who struggle with
alcohol addiction would recognize your
language the way you're talking to me
that you aren't fully being upfront with
everything and I don't know what that
means I don't know what that what that
is but there's
either she's got some really significant
challenges or um you're not you're not
being for that if I were to talk to her
I'd get a radically a very different
picture of you than what I'm getting
right now I would say if you talk to her
she would probably I would say it's the
the first
scenario the distance was created by my
dishonesty
basically because you lied one time
about having two beers no I lied that's
what I'm saying is I was dishonest
multiple times about how much I had
drank that one particular instance was
kind of the strug broke the camel's back
okay well here's my rule for moving out
to try to get some space to see if we're
going to save this
thing is number one there has to be a
specific time frame okay and I usually
don't wouldn't I would never recommend
unless there's physical abuse that it's
over 30
days so I'm out for 30 days and we have
some agreed touch points we will talk
talk I will pick the girls up we will we
have to negotiate these rules ahead of
time otherwise it's going to build
resentment frustration anger rage it's
going to be a false set of a false piece
so be very clear on the front and this
isn't just you out so that ah it's not
how that works in 30 days we're going to
get back together and have a
conversation I strongly recommend you'll
have a a marriage counselor that y all
work through this thing together and
then I would ask her for a specific
items not of things you got to work on
because what you're going to do like any
good person recovering from addiction is
you're going to make her falling back in
love with you your new addiction and
you're going to do a bunch of things to
try to make her
happy and that's not the point what you
want to do is say what are the things I
need to do that can help you feel
safe and then I'm gonna challenge you
man to go to AA for a season no go to
your counseling stuff but go to a
meeting every day because I think you're
going to find out about
yourself all right you can't lose weight
for her you can't just stop drinking for
her because you're going to find
alternative things to keep that distance
from her and it's gonna
in you see what I'm saying she thinks in
her mind if he'll just quit doing X then
I'll be okay and you quit doing X and
she's realizing I still don't feel that
same way and you here's the final thing
y'all can't go
back what what was is
over and you'll have to decide are we
gonna build something new
right do you and I've laid that out to
her I said I'm I'm totally in with
rebuilding it with you and she's just
not in that place right now okay well um
I
think it sounds like you're going
willingly
right I mean I don't want to do anything
else that's going to possibly expedite
us getting a divorce or anything so okay
um I'm just trying to do what I need to
do to hopefully get things going in the
right direction all right I want you to
um Google it's Terry re t e r r y r e a
l Terry re I think it's the 10 rules of
a of a
separation okay I want y'all to use that
as a guidepost and I want you to bring
your counselor in on it also and that's
going to set the stage for this 30-day
thing to we're going to take a break
from each other I'm going to start
getting myself well because I'm worth
being well she is going to let some of
the Smoke Clear from her Anger from her
rage from her not feeling safe inside
her own house and begin to ride it like
here's where we're headed here's what I
here's what I need to feel safe you're
going to have some regular touch points
you're going to be upfront and adults
about with the kids and then in 30 days
youall are going to circle back and that
30 days meeting might be in a
counselor's office I can't recommend
this enough that at that 30-day meeting
you each write each other a letter and
read it to each other otherwise it's
it's either going to be a blubbery mess
or a you're going to forget stuff but
have a letter at the end of that 30day
period that you can hold and read and
hand to that person when you're done and
um and vice versa she's got to have one
for you and maybe it's I need another 30
days I need 15 more days or I'm not
coming back I'm going to file for
divorce and I want to do this amicably
or I'm ready to build something
completely new with you but I'm going to
be super super
honest something in the way you're
talking to me says you're not done
yet and that's if there's one place
where people will hold you accountable
it's in
AA and I would love for you to go to a
meeting and it may just be that you have
two little daughters and you have run
out of tools I don't know how to love in
my house I don't know how to be a dad to
two little girls I've got to get some
more tools and so just creating space
and distance which is what alcohol gives
you which is what dishonesty gives you
which is what Netflix gives you just
creating that space so you don't do
something wrong ends up poisoning the
whole house maybe that's what it is and
you need to learn some parenting skills
Etc but you got to repair your
relationship with your
wife or she's going to have to call it
like she is kind of circling the wagons
it's just and it feels like it's headed
that way um terry.com pull out that that
checklist and go down that road and then
holler back at me after 30 days man I'd
love to see where you're where you're
going what you're doing if you want to
read your letter to her um I would love
that but I don't want you creating a
30day writing a 30-day screenplay so you
can act as though you're the person she
needs I want you to begin to get well
for you at the end of the day that's the
only person you can take care of in
control we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey what up what up it's delone
this time of year can be so hard and
Seasonal effective disorder is real when
I moved here the time change caught me
off guard it was dark at 4:30 and I was
ready for bed at like 6:45 at night
things weren't as fun even food tasted
different and now I know how to prepare
my body I go outside and enjoy nature I
stick to an exercise routine I got a
light box and I intentionally connect
with people another thing that has
helped me therapy therapy can be a
bright spot even when the Sun goes down
too soon something positive to help you
feel grounded and give you the tools to
manage the way your body is changing
during the seasons if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
better help is flexible because it's
totally online so it can fit into your
schedule just fill out a short
questionnaire to get matched with the
licensed therapist and you can switch
therapist anytime for No Charge find
your bright spot this season with better
help visit betterhelp.com dealone today
to get 10% off your first month that's
betterhelp
hp.com SL
delone all right let's go out to
Lancaster Pennsylvania and talk to the
incredible Lily what's up
Lily hey Dr John how you doing could not
be better couldn't be better what's
up um so I'm just gonna read you my
original submission if that's all right
um just for backstory um my fiance and I
got engaged back in May of this year um
you know he had the blessing
conversation went really well um and
then about two months after we got
engaged my parents sat me down and told
me they were as essentially taking back
the blessing and rattled off to me an
extensive list of character flaws and
red flags that they saw in my fiance and
our relationship and ever since then you
can't triple stamp a double
stamp yeah it was it definitely caught
me very off guard um it was very very
devastating to me but um ever since then
I've kind of been struggling with a lot
of relationship anxiety and just kind of
general anxiety and almost like
depressive mood of course um of course
yeah yeah yeah yeah so that so Lily your
body's working perfectly okay as it
should yeah good grief there's no
takebackspace
sing off of me and kind of manipulating
me and rushing me into things that I
wasn't ready for didn't want to do um
they didn't really like his career
choice um what is they don't they don't
get a vote about that what's his career
choice so he it's a little bit more on
unconventional side um
he is he a magician he like does he is
how did you know I just made that up I
promise you're joking no I just made
that up dude no he's so he's a magician
and a juggler but he works in Ministry
so he tours to churches the Jesus
juggler yeah I mean oh my gosh he's
gonna use that now he is going to use
that I would probably sit my daughter
down and be like hey listen listen
um oh gez okay
so how long have y'all been
together we've been together close to
two years now I'm not going to lie I'm
amazing at this job can we just say that
out loud Jesus juggler magician all
right so all right take that back I'm
not that amazing so
um here's a couple of
things
um oh geez I don't know how to get into
this
um let me just say it like this number
one they don't get a
vote um I think with all of my heart
they love you yeah and they would not be
pulling the rip cord like they have if
they
didn't um I also think that people who
love us and think they have our best
interest at heart often
um insert themselves as a last minute
last Stitch effort like a truck is
coming right at you I'm GNA scream and
yell and shove you out of the way and
you may Bang Your Head on the concrete
but you didn't get hit by a truck and I
feel like that's what they're doing
right here okay yeah
um and I am very skeptical very
skeptical
of unsolicited
advice where somebody
else the person giving the advice does
not have any skin in the
game okay yeah and what I mean by that
is they do have skin in the game like
it's going to affect their Thanksgiving
or their precious little daughter but
their unsolicited
advice implodes your life not
theirs yeah definitely okay and so I'm
always skeptical of that if you had sat
down and said hey I'm feeling
uncomfortable can I ask yall some just
hard questions about marriage and dating
and getting together and then like
people call my show I I I got skin in
the game if I keep giving wrong answers
people gonna quit listening to the show
and I'm I'm gonna have to get another
job right yeah so my question to you is
is any of the stuff they said does any
of it ring true has any of this stuff
had a a friend of yours well y'all just
having a drink or having C coffee
mention something similar along these
lines honestly no I haven't had anyone
else in my life really Express these
concerns about my relationship with him
or just him in general okay uh for the
most part everyone's reacted really
positively to him being around and you
know our relationship um I'm not going
to lie there's been some things that I
feel like I've almost been extra
critical of since that conversation MH
just kind of in light of it and I don't
that's where I kind of struggle
with whether I'm trusting myself and my
intuition and trusting my parents or if
I'm just looking really deeply into
things that don't need to be looked
really deeply into and they're just kind
of like give me an
example I mean I think the biggest thing
that
kind of rang true with them is I
struggle with his immaturity sometimes
and he is very emotionally mature I
would say even more emotionally mature
than me in a lot of cases um but just
kind of his like sense of humor
sometimes he's not very socially aware
um and I kind of equate that to being a
little bit more on the immature side I
don't have any experience with that at
all not even a little
bit or maybe one day like me he'll make
a living doing
that well moves away from Jesus juggling
then yeah and let's be honest if he's
still doing Jesus juggling when he's
when he's in his 40s then I mean maybe
but here's the thing
um I I guess maturity is probably on a
spectrum I made a joke the other day at
the dinner table and my 13-year-old
looked at me and was like Dad when are
you going to grow up right so I mean
part of me is like yeah but also there's
there's there is a social awareness to
that right and then there's there's a
time and a place and in my house at my
table with my 13-year-old I can make
jokes that I'm not going to make out in
public or whatever but he is a m a m i
mean a magician and a
juggler so I would hope he's got like a
sense of humor that would match that but
oh absolutely yeah here's what I here's
what I would do I I is is there one or
two things that are sitting heavy on
your soul if he thinks fart jokes are
funny and butt crack jokes are funny
that I
mean it that can be as simple as hey
there's a time and place and this isn't
funny here yeah and if he goes hey you
know what forget you you you this is who
I am then your parents are right run
from that guy yeah but if he goes I know
dude I need to like just work on time
and place you're right then he sounds a
lot like a guy I know named John and he
could probably come a long way you know
fair enough yeah and he definitely he
definitely is the ladder like yeah he's
just been he's honestly been an awesome
partner for me and I I kind of feel bad
going through all of this
anxiety with him he supported me so much
through it and really fostered my growth
through it which has been amazing um and
I just feel bad that I have all of this
relationship anxiety about a person who
I know is very good for me and a very
healthy partner don't feel bad about it
your parents said if you select him you
are unselecting us they we are opting
out of relationship with you if you
choose this yeah that's not something to
shy away from you need to head directly
into that
that's a very real thing and I'm not
somebody who just is like screw them
dismiss what they said no they love you
I don't believe they would have done
this in unless you tell me no they've
got a history of being super overbearing
and overprotective and over dramatic my
whole life is that
true
um I would say to an extent they're also
just very very critical people and I
would say leaning towards judgmental
people and I kind of feel like sometimes
I have that perspective on people and
their slip ups and ways course that's
that's the that's the air you've been
breathing for your whole life yeah and
that's yeah I just always try and
explain to my fiance like that also
comes from a place where I'm very
critical of myself
and so as hard as I am on him sometimes
I'm just as hard if not more hard on
myself sure well I don't think
so let me put over on one side you can
get married and be in love and have a
great time that's over here number two
is hey if you're going to be Jesus
juggler if you're going to travel around
churches doing magic shows I want to see
a business
plan yeah because I'm about to Hitch my
entire life to you and if your business
plan is um you just sitting at home
waiting for churches to book you or for
clubs to book you or birthday party
parties to book you that's not good yeah
I love you I'll still marry you but
we're not I'm not I'm not signing up for
this definitely if he says no no no I
have a very clear plan I make this many
calls a day I send out this many press
kits a day um I also I only want to be
doing big theaters or I only want to be
doing big churches for X dollars but I
also know that I got to pay bills so
I'll do birthday parties and all that
kind of stuff on the site even though
it's not glamorous great
that's somebody who's out hustling and
will he be doing this in 10 or 15 years
probably not but the experience of
hustling the experience of walking into
God knows how however many different
situations and learning how to read a
room and learning how to be kind and
open to people learning how to deal with
business that's why I'm where I'm at
right now because of those
skills yeah and so I I wouldn't those
skills help me run be the chief student
affairs officer at the univers I mean it
those those skills are helpful anywhere
you go and so um I don't have any
problem with him trying to make a living
as a magician I'm worried if you think
he's going to be 36 and still trying to
eek it out but that's you guys sitting
down and being honest about the business
plan of this whole thing yeah right yeah
and we've definitely yeah we've done
that and I completely trust him I've
seen him put in the hard work and get I
mean this was his first year going
full-time with his own business and it's
been more successful than either of us
anticipated because he's really just
he's worked really really hard at it
what does success mean how much money
will he make this calendar year this
calendar year he'll make
$50,000 yeah that means he's hustling
good for him yeah do your parents know
that um I've tried to talk to them about
it um they've expressed concern a couple
times not seriously but they've just
kind of asked about it um and I always
have tried to explain to them how much I
see him work on a day-to-day basis the
way that he really he doesn't really
take many breaks um hey h how much how
much of this is your parents don't want
to tell their friends at the country
club that when they say well what does
he do and they say he's a magician how
much of this is just protecting their
own fragile little identities cuz now
I'm starting to get mad at them I was
their side when this call first started
but now I'm starting to turn on on your
parents yeah I I think in retrospec of
as I've moved further away from the
conversation I've kind of started to
feel that way too okay um I I think it's
probably a little bit of that a little
bit of an appearance thing I think
they're also afraid that we're just
going to struggle financially and
they've always just wanted me to be
comfortable and well taken care of in
that way that's something that they
really
prioritize so
so are you working kind of works twofold
yes I am working what do you do um it's
kind of a bunch of different things uh
I'm event coordinator for one business
um I'm a saleswoman for another business
it's just kind of like a lot of little
jobs what what would your tax return say
you made this
year um I believe it'll be around
$45,000 okay so you almost have a
six-figure household
yeah at this point I mean this first
year
out yeah okay
um here's what I would do if I were this
is this is just me here's what I would
do I would sit down with two of my
friends that I trust I'd
call two buddies and I would say I need
to go meet with y'all for coffee or meet
with y'all for a drink and here's what
just happened mom and dad said this this
this and this and
um it kind of rattled me because they
withdrew their
blessing and I'm asking you all am I
crazy or are they crazy and I please
please please tell me the
truth yeah and have them speak openly
into your life and if they say I don't
see that at all like yeah he's a he's
like a professional juggler that's not
normal but no he loves you and takes
care of you and shows up I wish he
hadn't made those you know jokes about
bras at the funeral but you know I I
give them an opportunity to speak into
it okay yeah and so that's just friends
speaking into it the second thing is is
you're G to have to come up with some
sort of circle back with your parents
exactly that's my biggest concern right
now hey here's the deal they have drawn
their
boundary if you're into to this we are
withdrawing from
you and I think you can Circle up and
say Hey I've thought about what you said
and based on this conversation let's
just assume your friends say no your mom
and dad are nuts they always have been
um we've watched them just beat you down
for all these years um or no they're
actually right this isn't
good um yeah then Circle back with your
parents and say hey uh I got some
additional wisdom some additional
whatever this wedding is happening on
this
day and if you choose to not be in
relationship with me because of that
that's a choice y'all are making y'all
are grown-ups y'all get to make that I
want youall to know that it will break
my heart but um I respect your decision
as adults and I wish you all the
best and then you got to go make some
grown-up decisions because that's
probably going to come with some money
that they're going to put towards the
wedding it's probably going to come with
all sorts of hooks and strings and your
integrity and your relationships aren't
worth
that however heavy it feels right
now yeah you know you know what I mean
yeah absolutely but don't cash out your
integrity and your
relationship for a fancy
wedding yeah no that's definitely
definitely not a plan gross that's gross
yeah yeah and also don't just throw away
wisdom from two people who love you
however misguided it might be double
check it with somebody else
yeah why does that make you
nervous it honestly it really doesn't
and I actually have in the aftermath of
it I have done that with a couple people
that I really trust and those are the
people that are telling me that they
don't see what my parents see and they
don't they're honestly they're almost as
blindsided As I Am by my parents
reaction cool um so yeah I've honestly
already kind of gotten that confirmation
from other people that I
trust um and now I'm just I'm just
wondering how to come to my parents and
have that conversation because I can't
imag direct as possible okay how old are
you I'm 24 yeah it's grown up
time it really is there is no way to
leave this conversation feeling
good there is a way to leave this
conversation feeling gross and there's a
way to leave this conversation feeling
empowered but you will not feel good
yeah and I think taking that off the
table I want you to say what you have to
say truthfully and with dignity and
respect don't go in there bombing them
like they bombed you because then you
become
them yeah right
but be honest I'm marrying him I've
checked in with some other people that I
hold in with high value and I actually
feel in my guts that y'all are
embarrassed to tell your friends that
your daughter married a magician and I
hate that but y'all made that choice and
yall get to do that because you're
grown-ups yeah but we're getting married
on this day I would love it if y'all are
there but y'all have made it clear they
not going to be and so uh my door is
always
open and then that conversation's
over and here's the other
thing most of those conversations in
that kind of moment when a a basically a
child is asserting their adulthood
okay it's your mom and dad will go to
fight or flight and protection for their
little girl and their ego and their
reputation and their how dare you you do
what we say all that
crap that's not the the conversation to
unravel everything and talk through all
of their
points okay there's a conversation I
need to say this and it's going to take
15 minutes or 10 minutes and then we can
set up a time later to Circle back and
have the the more in-depth
conversation sure and maybe you write
them a letter maybe you read the letter
maybe you send it to them and say Mom
and Dad I'm mailing you a letter that's
kind of got things outlined and then I'm
I'm I would love to set up a time that
we can have lunch or something um or
breakfast in the future and talk about
it but this isn't we're not going to do
a 2hour he said she said up and down all
around oh my gosh you're making the
worst decision we're not doing that this
time I'm going to just say what I'm
going to say and I'm going to move on
and then we'll Circle back and have the
harder conversation when all the smoke
is cleared very similar to firing
somebody the day you tell somebody the
moment you tell
somebody I'm letting you go you're fired
that is not the time to negotiate to go
through everything and then this and
then all that should have happened and
the moment somebody gets a hint that
it's over every defense mechanism they
have every fight or flight every ego
every everything is on point so you
Circle back you say I'll meet with you
next week I meet with you in 10 days
we'll set up a time and I'll I'll hear
it all and they may come back Furious
and enraged as part of the grief cycle
they may come back at peace and say dude
this is right I'm sorry I acted this way
they may come back any number of ways
but at least some of the emotion has
dialed down and they can begin to think
through what next steps look like and
then we'll go from
there I hate it for you I hate it if you
have if you're with somebody and it's
wrong I hate it for you that your mom
and dad said we're so excited for you
and then they Circle back and they they
withdrew and they put down a boundary
that said him or us I hate the whole
thing but when you say I do that's a
very grown-up decision it's
forever and with grown-up decisions come
grownup consequences and grownup
responses and this is exhibit a I wish
it wasn't the case it's not how any of
us would draw it up we want mom and dad
to write or die with us but your mom and
dad have said we draw a line right here
and now you get to make that
same that same choice that same
decision not going to feel good you can
feel gross or you can feel empowered and
I hope you choose
empowerment we'll be right
back hey good folks delone here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time those become healthy
habits they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that is help me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world world and they're giving you three
free months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling Hall makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Hall is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com dealone today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hall.com
dealone for 90 days
free all right we're back hey it's time
for the next installment of the six
daily choices series these have spun up
all over the internets and I'm so
grateful that you are watching these and
listening and showing them today's
choice is health and healing this idea
that man if your body's not well in
whole if you haven't dealt with that old
trauma if you haven't dealt with your
metabolic challenges your weight
challenges your movement
challenges your body is going to respond
in all different kinds of ways including
this perv iive sense of anxiousness that
something's not
okay and that's not popular to talk
about it's uncomfortable to talk about
everybody skirts it and evades it and it
was one of those things that I felt like
I was lying if I didn't talk about the
importance of taking care being a good
Steward of our bodies time is now the
statistics are against us they're super
clear and we have everything Food Water
Shelter
resources and yet we are sicker than we
could possibly imagine nobody would have
predicted this so check this out this is
one of the six daily choices choose
health or healing here we
go please hear me on this you can't
outthink anxiety you can't sit in a dark
room and get all the right thoughts in
the right order and neglect your body
[Music]
[Applause]
so when I think back to when I was
completely burned to the ground with
anxiety with burnout with just chronic
stress day after day after day I had a
whole bunch of graduate degrees I was
surrounded by some of the smartest Minds
in the world and I committed myself to
solving anxiety but all along the way I
completely neglected the vessel that
that was carrying me all over the place
I started skipping workouts I started
eating junk food in garbage I stopped
seeing a counselor cuz I didn't have
time I had these feelings about things
that happened to me in the past and I
shoved them down because I had important
intellectual work to do and my body was
sick my body was overcome with past
traumas my body said I
quit we're a culture that has
information on everything a blog post
and a Wikipedia page Ag and a YouTube
channel for everything we can imagine
for most of us our pain won't be solved
with more intellect our pain is solved
by sitting down and exhaling and to look
at our one precious body and say you're
worth taking care
[Music]
of so when I talk about healing I'm
often talking about dealing with past
trauma and we think of trauma like the
big car wreck right the big plane crash
right those big before before and after
moments and that is trauma that's acute
but there's also other kinds of trauma
like secondary trauma if you are a nurse
You're a social worker you're a
counselor every day people come to you
and say will you please help me and so
where an acute trauma might be like
somebody dropping a cinder block in your
backpack cumulative trauma is the every
day somebody comes and hands you a few
Pebbles and the next day a few Pebbles
the next day a few Pebbles and over time
the weight of that backpack is the exact
same as the weight of somebody with a
cinder block there's also Collective
trauma what happens when a whole country
goes to war or when I don't know an
illness sweeps across the globe right
that's a collective trauma that we all
experience together and then there's
another kind of trauma that we don't
talk about very often the trauma of
neglect the things you should have got
when you were a kid you should have had
a safe place to come home to from school
Dad should have have chosen you over the
bottle mom should have chosen you over
the cell phone and what happens is our
body puts a GPS pin in those moments and
25 years later you get married and you
found the Romantic partner of your
dreams and they get close to you and
your body says whoo we remember what
happens when someone gets close and it
sounds the alarms that guy is not safe
she's going to hurt us too how many of
you feel 2 in apart from someone but to
2 thousand miles away from them and
healing from trauma is almost always
about teaching your body I know we
weren't safe then we got hurt badly back
then but we're going back in now and we
might get hurt again cuz vulnerability
is the only path to friendship and love
and connection but that's the path to
Healing from
[Music]
trauma so when I talk about health I'm
talking about your physical body and
it's time we're honest as a country
we're way overweight our metabolic
health is a mess and there is no mental
health without physical health you can't
build a home without first building a
foundation and a foundation to Great
mental and emotional health is having a
healthy body if you have chronic pain if
you're struggling with obesity if your
joints hurt your neck hurts your back
hurts it's almost impossible to have
good mental and emotional
health few things are more contentious
than the nutrition religion Wars that
are upon us I'm keto well I'm vegan well
I'm carnivore well I'm rational and
sensible enough what you're going to
find is that for most people most of the
time hold your hats just about any diet
will do
if you make some hard hard choices about
consumption and movement and we've
created a world for ourselves we don't
have to move very much we take
escalators up the stairs we take
escalators down we fly in Planes cross
country almost overnight we've withdrawn
movement from The Human
Experience it's killing us and so if you
want to choose a non-anxious life you
have to choose movement and like
nutrition I'm not going to get into the
workout Wars it can be a 20 M run it can
be a walk to your mailbox and back it
can be a 10-minute wait room session in
your garage I don't care you have to
move most of us know the data we should
all be getting about 7 to 9 hours of
sleep and we also know that most of us
think we're pretty hardcore and we're
doing just fine on four 5 or 6 hours of
sleep for 99.9% of us we're not our body
IES aren't getting that deep wave
restorative sleep our bodies aren't
getting that deep REM sleep that takes
out the garbage in our minds that
restores and heals our body and prepares
us for the next day and for many of us
sleep is hard we have racing thoughts
we've got things to do we've got kids
running everywhere and yet if we don't
prioritize sleep everything else in our
life will suffer the less sleep you get
especially over time the more anxious
you're bound to
feel being perfect getting it all done
accomplishing Health accomplishing
healing is a Fool's errand you'll never
be all the way there wouldn't it be
awesome if we could brush our teeth once
a week we could do it so good on Monday
morning that we didn't have to brush our
teeth for the rest of the week that
would be amazing we can't I got to do it
twice a day similarly when you choose
health and healing you make that choice
for the rest of your life some days it's
harder some days it's easier I showed up
to this shoot today these guys they
brought a box of donuts I chose a donut
right but it's part of a bigger picture
this my life most of the time health and
healing should be relatively simple it's
hard it's a complete 180 from how most
of us live our lives
but if you just think am I being a good
Steward of what I'm putting in my body
am I moving am I willing to sit down
across from somebody and say I got hurt
bad and here's what happened very very
hard things but simple things and if you
feel yourself complicated or if you feel
yourself sitting with a professional and
they're telling you this and this and
this and this maybe time to move on
because the truest masterminds will tell
you it's just three or four or five or
six buckets over and over and over
again just like brushing your teeth
choosing health and healing is a choice
you're going to make every day for the
rest of your
life you're worth that
choice hey what's up deloney here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronic stressed at some point in my new
book building a non-anxious life you'll
learn the six daily choices that you can
make to get rid of your anxious feelings
and be able to better respond to
whatever life throws at you so you can
build a more peaceful nonanxious life
get your copy today at john.com
all right we're back as we wrap up
today's show dude Nathan Nate Dog you
had a great joke during the call about
the daughter marrying the Jesus juggler
and
magician uh yeah I had uh what what did
I say oh I said that the guy is uh he
should say to uh the parents I got a
magic trick for you I'm going to make
your blessing
disappear good job good job
Nathan um that would have been awesome
if his parents if her parents had done
that like we give you our blessing
hooray we're going to take that back
here's
why magic magic magic and it disappeared
all right as we wrap up today's show
it's actually not funny at all I'm
hurting for everybody on that
one song by a band that's a body part
that Kelly doesn't have I realized I
couldn't have said that any weirder
sorry about that songs by the band
har it's called Magic Man and it goes
like this cold late night so long ago
when I was not so strong you know a
pretty man came to me I've never seen
eyes so blue you know I could not run
away it seemed we'd seen each other in a
dream seemed like he knew me he looked
right through me try to understand I'm a
magic
man so
good maybe that guy should just read
these lyrics to his future in-laws and
they'd be like oh we missed it maybe
that's the case love you guys see you
soon